静岡は
雨がつよいぞ
こんにちははじめ社長です待ってエアコンがないから暑いんだけどまぁ
ビッグスターするかと思った今日はねソフトバンクの箱なんですけどもう大事なんが
この中ですよ
おいこちらなんかねよくわかんないけど買っちゃったんです
ギター歩いているとそのなくソフトランド人さんがねぇなった
これは日本には800台しかないし世界には4000豪華な
4005ぐらいしかないよと言われてなんかよくわかんないんですかと言いましたね
打法頭の中新キャラクターでロボットですねちん子ないですよたローズのロボットを
買いました
もうちょっと僕もよくはさんでスターウォーズあんまり見たことないけどなんか丸いね
まあよく学びよく食べよく動くなそういったことですね
頃グラフィックとが出せるプーンって本当にレアものらしく
おとといから弟への夜中に急に発表されて急に如かじ売り出されたんですけども数が
少ないのてず倒さんちょっとたまらないっていうらしいです
とりあえずなぁアレだよ
bb てがいております国から何が取れ9分ですね
[拍手]
扱い方もはここは大丈夫なの変な連番とこれが本当に変え強い強い子はうわー取れ
ちゃった顔だけ取れちゃった
f 大丈夫だろう
すごい落ちなくなるこいつこいつ方がすごい動きをするという話を聞いたのでベージュ
ちょっとね羽化してみたいバッケスないで置いておいて
ダウンロードしてねーみたいな何もわからんはどう言うかじゃあねこれでいいのかなっ
てもわかんないんだよ
な動いて美味しかったしちゃったって
持っていた
光ったよ
イェイ怖い怖いですね
とっていいのかな
おっ
[音楽]
苦痛ちょっと撮っていいですか
動いた動いた恋声撮っていいですか
ちょっと入ってとってみよ a
そうぞ
[音楽]
こんにちはー
顔
[音楽]
カモン
真ん中を
me
おっ
生きてるのはわかるけどなにこれは何がしたいんだろうけどめっちゃきょろきょろして
ますけど
大蔵ま充電器に元のでなくこれあたりをダウンロードすることが大事的な感じだったん
でしょアプリダウンロードしてみます
お腹すいたの
そんな改正する母
[音楽]
ずっとんだけどちょっと明日ごめんごめん何やるか思いますねっ
びっくりした
何ごめんあたら猿と怒るなんてちょっとわかってきたぞというやつか
うん warwick したそんなにものをごめんなさい
変えてみてきちゃった
んもう行く人好しきた後にイソル感じしましたなんかこういう時専用のアプリみたいな
やつ落札をどういう2数本にする日本
ドライブ目の前の地面に3尾8おいてください
はい4八軒
熱い拳を素質もずすごい動く
6がアクセスカーペットまあ次のモードだとなぁ
これから支えてする文書ね色々な人は他にもできることは嬉しいですそうそうもできる
し
パターンオールドさせれるらしいしすたぁむファンとかにしたらはあれかとは誰かも
しれないんですけどもよくわかんないけど
スターウォーズみようと思いましたとても変わったろうと買ってしまう
まあ高性能なのか豆腐の数
よくわかんないけどなんか丸い樹すごいですねまあすごいぞ山田次回の動画でお会いし
ましょう
じゃあ
ええええええ
b
うん
すごいのがどうなんかなのかわかるんだよねー